depuis cet été les polices municipales
des clés sous-bois et de plaisir ne font
plus qu'une cette initiative menée par
les conseils municipaux des deux
communes devrait répondre à l'une des
principales problématique le manque
d'effectif car au clés sous-bois la
police municipale n'existait plus on
avait exactement la même vision des
choses c'est-à-dire une police efficace
mais de proximité et que les sous-bois
n'en avaient pratiquement plus des
policiers donc donc on s'est dit
pourquoi pas essayer de nous réunir et
de voir comment on pourrait monter en
puissance et surtout devenir attractif
et efficasse pour la population parce
que le but premier c'est bien celui-là
renforcer les effectifs c'est donc
l'ambition première de cette fusion ça
va nous permettre d'attirer plus de
policiers municipaux aujourd'hui il y a
21 ou 22 policiers municipaux l'objectif
en mettant des moyens communs nous
espérons arriver à 30 ce qui permet
d'avoir plusieurs brigades au niveau de
la cette police de proximité et pour le
moment cette initiative semble porter
ses fruits deux personnes ont déjà été
recrutées et parmi eux il y a David
désiré directeur de police municipale
intercommunale il assure depuis quelques
mois la coordination de cette fusion
séparément les communes avaient des des
des moyens qui leur permettaient de
limiter leur action dans l'espace et
dans le temps là le fait que les deux
communes fusionnent leurs moyens vont
permettre de par exemple d' LG la plage
horère de peut-être tout un tas de
choses qui vont des perspectives qui
vont être beaucoup plus importantes les
choses évolueront avec avec un
calendrier qui reste encore à définir
mais les choses c'est clair vont vont
évoluer mais dans le dans le but
principal c'est de pouvoir rendre une
comment dire une mission de service
public aux administrés des deux communes
le local principal de la police
intercommunale se situe à plaisir de son
côté la ville des clés sous-bois
conserve un petit bureau annexe les
habitants pourront s'y rendre pour
déposer des déléances prendre des
renseignements